no estamos ante fenómenos directamente
vinculados a lo que es el calentamiento
global y el cambio climático
si es correcto pero es muy importante
tocar este tema y reconocer que los
huracanes al igual que otros fenómenos
meteorológicos tormentas etc son parte
integral del clima y como tal es todo
que el clima pues va a dejar su huella
sobre los huracanes
o sea también para diferenciarla y
huracanes digamos y temporadas también
en los que quizás son más comunes pero
estamos en un momento del planeta en el
que quizás son más extremos
y ahí hay temporadas de huracanes aquí
en el atlántico la temporada oficial que
la madre naturaleza reconozca siempre va
del primero de junio al último día de
noviembre sus seis meses es cuando se
dan la mayoría de los huracanes del
atlante sin embargo el calentamiento
global ha alterado
considerablemente lo que consideramos
los patrones normales
desde tormentas y huracanes y estamos
viendo como en los últimos años se han
venido dando
mucho más fuertes
más
húmedos en el sentido de que producen
más lluvias torrenciales debido a que el
calentamiento permite que la atmósfera
retenga más agua y todo esto combinado
ha llevado a estos últimos impactos que
hemos visto que son mucho más fuertes
claro estamos bien interesantes los
resultados del calentamiento global y es
que siempre se pensaba que es cuando un
huracán toque tierra a medida que ya
penetra tierra adentro se debilita
rápidamente
pero esto no está sucediendo hoy en día
y por tu ejemplo
por el calentamiento global
a la atmósfera a repetir mucha agua
con la mayor producción de lluvia de los
huracanes el suelo se anega entonces esa
humedad adicional le da energía cuando
está la tormenta en el caso de ir por
ejemplo les tomo 16 horas de entrar
tierra adentro antes de que va a hacer
su categoría de huracán a tormenta
tropical y lo hemos visto con otros
huracanes que han entrado por la zona
del norte del golfo y luego atraviesan
en los estados de sobre eeuu e inclusive
vuelvan a salir de atlante y durante
períodos de dos a veces hasta tres días
permanecen como ciclones tropicales y
esto no se veía hace muchos años pero
ahora es mucho más común derecho
señor ahora no eres ahora brevemente nos
queda poco menos de un minuto pero de
continuar esta tendencia hacia que
escenario global se encamina el planeta
pero la tendencia el calentamiento
continúa eso eso es indudable y lo que
podemos esperar es más
eventos extremas como estas
porque los los patrones normales
tradicionales sean alterados totalmente
y entonces pues lo que nos espera en ver
más extremos como huracanes
inundaciones o lo hemos visto
recientemente en europa y les hace como
eres